اذا هذه الصعوبات عمد حكام المصارف
المركزيه المكلفين بشكل اساسي اذا عمد
الحكام المكلفون بشكل اساسي بالحفاظ على
استقرار الاسعار الى معاوده زياده معدلات
الفائده وهو امر حذروا من انه سيتواصل في
20 23 غير ان هذه الاستراتيجيه تشدد الضغط
على الاقتصاد من خلال زياده كلفه الاقتراض
على الاسر والشركات ما يفاقم المخاوف من
الركود الامر نفسه ينطبق على الدول التي
ازدادت مديونيتها بعد الازمه الماليه
والازمه الصحيه وفي دليل على الاجواء
الاقتصاديه القادمه يتجه مؤشر ستاندرد
امبورس 5 اسوء عامل له منذ ازمه 2008
الماليه
لكن العالم ما زال بعيدا عن الركود المعمر
في 20 23 مع توقع نمو بنسبه 2.2% وفقه
منظمه الامن والتعاون في الميدان
الاقتصادي واثنين فاصل سبعه بالمئه صندوق
النقد الدولي الذي توقع في الاسابيع
الاخيره ان تكون فرص تسجيل اثنين بالمئه
فقط ازدادت لكن المملكه المتحده دخلت في
ركود ويعتقد من قبل الكثير من خبراء
الاقتصاد ان المانيا وايطاليا ستتبعان
فيما اضاف بن ماير رئيسها قسم تحليل
الاقتصاد الكلي في اكسفورد ايكونوميكس ان
الولايات المتحده الى القائمه ستضاف
وذلك خلال مقابل
[موسيقى]
اداء الولايات المتحده قد يكون افضل نسبيا
على المدى القريب وبشكل عام نتوقع ان تكون
الاقتصادات الناشئه افضل الاقتصادات